Let's go back to the beginning and talk
about really what is the main issues uh
with Egypt and the cops. So what I'd
like to do is a quick rundown of the
year in review as it were and especially
kind of home in on new trends developing
trends in the persecution because they
always have something new and exciting
for us stored. First of all, of course,
is more of the usual that we get, which
is the mob uprising, anger, violence,
attacks. And the most recent one, if you
go on the Coptic Solidarity website,
which I write for, you'll all the most
recent one, I think, was two weeks ago
somewhere in Minia where um they burned
Coptic homes and they were angry because
a Coptic man, I think, he got a permit
to put some sort of mobile apparatus on
his roof and all of a sudden, um, that
triggered them. And it triggers them of
course because somehow he's seen he's
trying to improve himself. He's trying
to be better than them. It actually goes
back to Sharia where there's
stipulations about a Christian can't
have a house higher than a Muslim's
house. Um so and if you even doubted
that there was that that was a religious
uprising the Muslims made sure to scream
out Allahbar. All right. So it was
definitely an they were um underscoring
the religious aspect obviously. And what
was actually good about that, if you've
seen that particular one, the one I'm
talking about from about two weeks ago,
I forget the name. Someone can tell me
if they know the name of the city. I
think it's in Minia, but um someone
videotaped it. A woman videotaped it, I
guess, with her phone. And you can just
you can hear the terror in her voice and
how just utterly traumatizing this
entire event is as she watches her
property burn as she watches Muslim men,
women, and children screaming and
looting and stealing.
[Applause]
[Music]
And so I think it was a you know when I
when you read a lot as I do and you
probably do and you encounter these
stories and um they they become just
very kind of dry and factual but in this
particular case I found it very
interesting. because you could hear the
woman's terror and um that's how they
all are. We just don't get that because
we usually just read a small story about
it. So any that's the Muslim mob
uprisings are still alive and well. And
then of course the entrenched
discrimination.
Um so for example past Easter I think e
holy week Easter week one or two of
those days universities made it a point
to schedule exams even though those are
Christian holidays which and then of
course conversely when Ramadan was in
effect the whole school was shut down
all of them and that caused problems and
the dir of churches and the sort of uh
overall discrimination was such that it
caused yet another Coptic funeral to be
held in the streets. Imagine people
because they're so they're deprived of
churches, they have to bury their loved
ones in the street and haveerary rights
in that kind of context. How demeaning,
how degrading, but that's the point. So
that sort of thing is um alive and well.
And another one of the new developments
of course is Egypt appointed a new grand
mut. If you dig into his background, you
find, of course, one of his famous
books, I think the equivalent of a
dissertation from his academic
background is an attack on Christianity,
the Trinity specifically. And the the
short and long of the whole book is that
Christians are ultimately kufur. So this
is the grand muty of Egypt, which tries
to put on a moderate face. And this man
behind the scenes has written a treaties
about how the Christians, the cops are
kufur, are infidels. And as you know, if
you are labeled a cafir, that
immediately puts you on the role of your
own enemy. You're someone who's to be
fought, discriminated, subjugated, and
kept down. So that's the new Grand Mui.
And speaking of, of course, Alhar also
this past year published a book
dedicated republished the book,
rededicated entirely to um destroying
churches in Egypt. The thesis is that
churches have no belonging in Egypt. And
it was written by some sheh from maybe
200 years ago but they reissued it and
republished it with a new introduction
and a new forward. And keep in mind alar
is who Pope Francis would meet with with
Ahmed alib
you know before he passed away and they
would hug and kiss and talk about
fraternal love etc etc and this is what
they're doing behind the scenes. So this
is the reality of it. But of more
interest as and lately so some sort of
new trends that we can mention is uh you
know if I reflect on it because I've
followed this particular topic for so
long is attacks on churches in Egypt and
all throughout the Muslim world but in
Egypt specifically were very common as
you know. I mean of course historically
we can go back and talk about thousands
of churches being attacked but in the
modern era um I believe I believe MGI
has given the number has given the
number of you know thousands of churches
since the modern era let's say in the
60s okay in the 70s have been attacked
in one way or the other many of them
torched and we're all familiar with this
and there's always you know whatever the
pretext is Muslims uprise and attack
churches for whatever reason but
something like maybe five six years ago
go. It stopped and it was nice and you
thought that was good and then all of a
sudden it started again with more
churches burning but in this time every
single one of them is an accident and
you don't see Muslims rioting and you
don't see anything. It just it just
happens. So the conclusion is either
something nefarious is happening. It's
business as usual, but under a new
guise, a more subtle guise. Or the
Coptic people are the most fireprone
accident people on the face of this
earth. Even though you would think
they'd want to be very careful with
their churches because their churches
are so uh embattled and few in number,
apparently of all the people in the
world, they just can't. They keep making
fires in their churches. So, I don't
know which sounds more plausible to you.
And uh but to help understand the
meaning of it, keep this in mind also.
Mosques and prayer halls which outnumber
uh Coptic churches in Egypt by 60 to1
ratio are seldom ever catch fire or
burn. So maybe in Egypt even the
circuits and the faulty wires are
radical too. I don't know. And they're
burning churches. The reason I actually
want to point this out is because it
seems like the sort of radical attacks
and that sort of thing are getting
becoming more sophisticated instead of
waiting on the rabble to do it and then
exposing yourself. I don't know, are
these the authorities? Are the are they
in cahoots with the radical shakes?
What's going on? And um so in one month
alone, I think in 2023 when this issue
started, nine or 10 churches burned in
one summer and in one of them 41 uh cops
were burned alive. And since then, the
most recent one I think was uh 10 days
ago, another church. And then before
that one was maybe two, three weeks,
another church in Egypt. And before that
was maybe 3 weeks. So this is an ongoing
thing there. There's more churches are
burning now more than when actual
jihadists and Islamists would rise up
against them. And it just, you know,
makes you wonder. It just shows you how
I think things are becoming a little
more clandestine and sophisticated. So
the other one is actually the abduction
of of women that we've heard a lot about
the abduction Islamization etc. When you
really think about it that too like the
um ongoing burning of churches which has
become more subtle and more
sophisticated has really taken on a very
sophisticated almost systematic way of
being done. Um and I think also it
includes authorities and and all these
different rings that focus and it's
become an art is my point. um these
things are becoming so subtle and so
much more systematic and obviously have
have a hand I would argue from the um
from the authorities. One of the things
that I think is very important to keep
in mind when you think of when you talk
about all these things that we're
talking about the abduction of the women
and you think about the authorities and
the police and the governor and you
wonder like why are they acquiescing?
Why do they cooperate? Why do they turn
a black eye a blind eye? And I think
what we have to remember and keep in
mind is that from their world view,
they're all the good guys. What they're
doing is actually good. When they abduct
a girl and they forcibly Islamize her,
in their mind, this is good. They're
altruistic,
you know, and I think it's important to
keep that in mind because if you don't,
you think that what they're doing is so
evil in their mind. And you know,
where's how do they have the conscience
to do this? But they actually have a
clear conscience. And that's why maybe
the policeman knows that this girl was
abducted, but um you know he's going to
turn a black eye, a blind eye because
you know what? This is better for her.
She's going to become a true Muslim and
not have to live as some foul infidel.
Okay. Or even in the Pakistani example
where they had the police authority
saying uh you know, inshallah, God
willing, she won't go back to her
parents because in his mind, yeah,
because now she's a good Muslim. She
doesn't have to go back to being a
career who's going to hell. I always
think this is an important element to
keep in mind because and it's a sad
element because it underscores how why
this issue is going to be so pervasive
because you're dealing with a people who
are doing something negative but in
their minds they're the good guys. Um so
that's obviously very problematic. But
the last thing I'll talk about which
again is also one of this these new
subtle sort of trends except it blew up
in their face is the St. Catherine
Monastery which uh is very recently just
happened May 29th. So May 29th
ironically um is when the news came out
that an Egyptian court had ruled that
St. Katherine Monastery which is the
oldest functioning monastery um in
history which has been there functioning
with monks since about a century before
Muhammad was born and Islam came into
the into play and which is a UNESCO
protected site which means this site
belongs to humanity as a cultural
heritage. it doesn't belong to any one
particular country and um Egypt on May
29th decided no this is our land and we
can do whatever we want and um you know
at least the Greek government and the
Greek patriarchs in the religious
hierarchy really got angry and responded
and many people don't understand but his
name is I think uh patriarch uhimos
what's that
>> yeah the patriarch of Athens and all
Greece and he made a he made a remark
and he said I can't believe today of all
days orthodox Oxy is being attacked
again. And his point of course is May
29th when this new information came out
is when another great Orthodox cathedral
was attacked and taken over by Muslims
which is the Haga Sophia in
Constantinople.
Um and they're both built by Justinian
in the fifth uh in the sixth century and
they're both UNESCO cultural sites. And
you're one in Turkey and again Turkey
took it over and turned it into a mosque
again after it had been a museum. And
even though Istanbul has 3,000 mosques,
apparently they need one more. And now
and now Egypt is doing the same thing.
But of course, after this backlash, CC
came up with some kind of proclamation
basically saying, "No, no, nothing's
going to happen. Nothing's going to
change. It's the same status quo." Um,
but according to some people, that's all
lies. And this is just he's trying to
diffuse the situation and just cover it
up and go away. And apparently what he's
trying to do, it's another move to help
improve the image of Islam in Egypt, the
overall Islamization of Egypt. If you're
unaware, under Cece, he's creating
what's called Islam City, uh, or Islam
Mission City, which is a major city
dedicated just to the teaching and
propagating of Islamic religion. Um, I
don't know where is it, New Cairo. It's
somewhere. It's on massive ground and
lots of acres. And they're building it.
They're going to it's going to give
scholarships to Muslims from all around
the world. and they're going to come and
be indoctrinated from alazar and then
unleashed on the world to go back to
their lands. So definitely there's this
islamization program going on with Cece.
And I think this St. Katherine thing
fits in it because what he'll probably
do is he'll keep the monastery as a
monastery. It's old. It's dilapitated.
But he's going to surround it with the
glories of Islam. And so it will be a
reminder that yes, this cathedral or St.
Catherine monastery is representative of
the old religions, Judaism,
Christianity, Moses, Christianity, etc.
And then it's going to be surrounded
with the glories of new Islam, the final
revelation. Um, so that's probably up
his sleeve. And that's what he's trying
to do. And you know, I guess the only
good news is this because because that
church is not by the it's not run by the
cops. the world actually heard about it
and cared because it's more of a
European Greek Orthodox thing and they
made enough noise to embarrass him. So,
we'll see where that goes. But overall,
that's I think what's been going on is,
you know, this kind of trend where the
same sort of radicalization exists and
the same sorts of problems, but they're
becoming a lot more sophisticated. You
know, the church thing where I'm telling
you they just catch fire constantly. You
can even see surveillance tapes where a
candle is just sitting there and then it
blows up and apparently. So I maybe are
they selling them candles that are booby
trapped or something to that effect?
I've never seen a people who every who
have so few churches but they keep
having accidental fires in them
constantly. And that's that's been a big
thing in the last 2 years especially
this year. Like I said this year it
seems every 3 weeks there's a new one.
So that's the current situation in Egypt
and and what we're all talking about and
what we're all trying to ameliorate. And
that's where it's at right now. And I
think that's one one that the fact that
it's becoming a little more subtle both
in the church issue and because these
have always been the big issues is the
church issue and the women issue, the
abduction issues and they're both taking
on a much more professional um guys and
I think that's by design an intention
and it's a lot more dangerous and you
know again keeping in mind that in their
minds they're the good guys. They don't
think they're doing anything wrong. They
think it's kind of to them, you know,
the end justifies the mean and the end
is I've made this person a good Muslim
or I've gotten rid of an infidel church.
So the means which are of less than just
kind of just um they they just look them
over.
[Music]
Zuna
[Applause]
balloon balloon balloon.
Balona
join
[Applause]
foreign.
[Music]
Come on up.
[Applause]
[Music]
Come on.
Yum.
Yummy.
[Music]
Help
me. Help me. Help me.
She loves
shech.